[Kelly] What's one time, like
a stranger changed your life.
- You know, there was
this experience I had
where I was going through a really, really
tough season in life
and I went to like the Glendale Galleria,
and I was walking around by
myself and this young man,
you know, I had to have
been like, I don't know,
maybe 24 or something like that
and he must've been like 19,
he walked up to me and he
said to me, he was like,
can I pray for you? And
I was like, oh my gosh.
I was like, yeah, yeah,
I would totally love that
and so we ended up
praying inside the mall,
in the middle of the
mall and then afterwards,
when I was walking to my
car, I was like, you know,
are you good? Do you have a ride home?
And he was like, well, you know,
I got one I'm working on it.
And I was like, oh, well,
if you want, I can give you a ride home
which of course at 24, at 39,
I wouldn't give anybody a
ride home that I don't know,
but at 24 I was just like, yeah, sure
if you need a ride, duh duh duh
and so we ended up sitting in my car
and then we ended up praying again
and then I ended up praying over him
and I just felt like a
bunch of stuff in my spirit
that it just had to be
God put it in my spirit
to just tell him about his life
and then we both ended up crying.
- wow
- Then he was like, you know,
afterwards, he was like,
okay, well, my ride's here
and I was like, well, let me,
let me get your number, you know?
So I got his number and I
plugged it in my phone as angel
and I went home and like
two days later I told my
girlfriends about it and
I just thought to myself,
you know what? Like, I want
to give this guy a call
and see how he's doing
and I went through my phone
and there was no angel in my phone at all.
- Like it was gone like then,
like you put it in and it was gone?
[Megan] It was gone.
- What?
- Yeah, yeah.
- Oh my gosh, so wait,
I wait, so I have a similar experience.
It's different but I just mean in the fact
that like someone was there
and then they were gone.
Like I was, it was the first
time I got up to sing a solo.
It was like a dessert theater
or something at our school
in like junior high and I,
it was the first time I
did something and I did it
and that show ended and, there were
a lot of different performers,
all their families were there
or whatever, grandparents,
all that kind of stuff.
And this older man,
like really old, like, dude,
like came up to me and I was actually,
this is such a weird thing about me,
but I didn't grow up around older people
and so I used to, when I
was a kid be terrified,
like I would get so panicked,
- Oh wow
- It just scared me
and I just didn't grow
up around anyone old.
So like I never saw and so it scared me.
So when he came up and talked to me,
I was just kind of frozen, but
he said the weirdest thing,
he said, all he said was,
you're going to do this
for the rest of your life.
And I was like, and I,
and I was like, what?
And I was so panicked. I
wasn't really, I was really,
[Megan] wow
- I was just like, run, run.
Like, I was like so scared.
And so I walked away and then
I felt horrible because I was
like, ugh, did I say, thank you?
And I was like,
and so then I started looking around
and I was looking for this
man and I couldn't find him.
I asked everyone there. Oh, it was like,
someone's grandpa was
here and like, came up,
no one had seen him.
I explained what he was wearing.
Nobody. And I never got to say, thank you.
So I don't know, if he was just
some old random dude that came in
or like, if he exists, I don't know.
I was like, what?
[Megan] Right. Anyway, it
was the weirdest thing ever
and then, you know, then
I, yeah, I'm a singer.
So anyway, it was, that's so
weird when stuff like that,
- That's crazy, I got chills
when you were telling that story.
- No, I'm telling you
and I got scared cause I was such,
I guess I was a very scared kid.
(Kelly laughs) In in a lot
of aspects. I got scared
cause I was like, well
then where did he go?
(Kelly chuckles)
Like, but it was,
[Meagan] Right
- but then I kind of, I'm
also a spiritual person,
I was like, was that like an angel?
Like I was like, was
that like somebody, like,
I don't know that if you
believe in it or not,
I just, it happened.
- I do